[Music]
hello everybody what's up wa a minute
three girls one wife something is
missing this guy there's my
boy I know you love your D go up say it
d
yes of course he loves you he just he
just doesn't show it on his face or with
his body language right Brew Junior come
on grw I need a word with you your
family's lives are at stake
what maxal has escaped from prison I'm
coming for my revenge
group we have to get to the safe house
it has
a I love this place
look she the most important part of a
heist is being aware of potential
dangers
she I Tred
[Music]
myself
out out out out
no
what
intruder
thanks
Ron
fire are you hot
burning Lisa does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he does
play
sports my tenda is grave I talk to him I
wish I was been
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa you hear that I'm sure it's the
girl Mak St she's very
odd your hand
I can't believe you're here do you like
music I have to cure oh not that kind of
cure they can't make you better I mean
they can but like emotionally no don't
cry your tears just smell so
bad send it back you need a
friend I love it it's not really my
style when you're inou L looks good she
could probably even do pageants if she
had
Congeniality your daughter has a little
psycho I open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
little I want to help you but Taffy says
it's a waste of time to try and fix a
way it's better just accept a guy's
father oh that's so
cute I have an idea there are bad people
out there come on Lisa it'll feel
good
that hand was going to do terrible
things you are being admitted impatient
lock
down I could get the clink for life or
the electric chair but I don't want to
die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of a
student I'm not making any more comments
you can talk to my lawyer really hope
this goth phas in soon you need a
friend look at that this is actually a
depiction of a swan but what do you see
what do you feel I feel you don't live
here Ronnie she could stay here but I
can't get a dog she's my sister there's
a difference yeah there's a difference
you can have sex in front of a dog
today's a big day for Anna they're doing
one of those big auctions
if I want to work at a top Art Gallery I
got to get a good recommendation and
there is no better recommendation than
Claire
Dupont good morning everyone Irwin's
clients are about to walk through that
door and I will not allow them to see
anything less than Perfection you what's
that massive oil spill on the back of
your shirt it's not like we work for a
sociopathic perfectionist or anything oh
God hello it's Claire your boss I need
an extra assistant I just got invited to
go to with CLA
Dupont you're not on this flight they
put you on one that leaves in 4 hours an
economy you've just been upgraded first
class I'm William what brings you to
London our London branch has called in
the director of the New York office wow
you seem a bit young to be the director
yeah the youngest director in company
history if you're not too busy being a
Swanky art director I would love sent
you out I lied to him about so many
things you are here for work not for
play I got you the reservation tickets
for this
evening you going to invite me inside
excuse me what happened to your manners
down T
ABI mom she's a director of an auction
house in New
York I would like you in charge of my
auction I'm going to do it I'm jealous
of your Han Montana LIF
dead Santos a word
please you're New Yorker and being a New
Yorker means that you fight every single
day Rocky B said that isn't he from
Philly he moved there from
[Music]
Brooklyn
it's the Nikki what up man are you
serious I have someone call me when you
get out of surgery all right you should
drive out there Rick's been there for
you guys your whole lives the devil's in
the details my friend it work Atlantic
City here we come what we got Ricky's
cancer's back why does it have to be
cancer won't everybody get worry yeah
and that's going to take us right into
the World
[Music]
Series
Ricky the best friend we never
had my baby's going to be born 6 weeks
early I was born 6 weeks early oh I want
to know where the hell you guys were
tonight we called every hospital and
there was no record of a Ricky St Nikki
you know all we did was tell one lie
hundreds and hundreds of times over many
many years if the truth does come out my
marriage is over what if we hire an
actor to play
sikki Rock Hard Rod x-rated rock and
roll impersonator I do a whole act wall
the wall top to bottom jizz jams thanks
for coming out tonight ladies and
gentlemen so horny to be here this is a
really bad idea
oh Jesus I've been cold turkeying the
booze Ricky s Nicki in the program
remember oh Rod it's not what you think
it is it's just piss I'm a hyper every
time I want you to admit that Ricky St
Nikki does not exist
[Applause]
heyer this is Ted summer Hayes my boss
Ted nice to meet you dig in the suit in
the seedlings man the seedlings the hair
plugs they're new right this is my hair
we're going to lose our job my best real
bab going to
epic night am I right guys
it I was really taken with your friend
Sten Nicki he's got brass balls on him
that guy that's why I hired him that's
awesome you just said what did you say
to say it when we're done we can't let
him out of our sight not only did I miss
the birth of my son but I let some porno
Peter Frampton impersonator snip his and
we're done Nicki you are unbelievable
show's over rod it's Ricky Ricky sikki
is it real my job sucked at no friends
but now I have all those
things are you a fraud sir what she
talking
about it's not we got to get rid of
him every time he tries to make a point
it's like he's smoking invisible dogs
dear God it's true who support now it
looks like I'm cupping the
[Music]
balls
Hi Well lookie lookie she is the perfect
fit I promise did she even see you she
was about
to what are you doing don't do
this no
[Music]
no
hi
oh God
starts this is just so exciting what is
happening well that's a perfectly
understandable question give num I'm an
if get it imaginary friend how are kids
grew up so we need new ones you could
save all of us all of who and don't say
ifs let him say it or I think his head
may actually
explode fine
[Music]
thank you you ready for
this there's no telling who's behind
that door
today we have to help them yes we
do
not going to ask you again put some
pants on you're freaking everyone
out starting to see why I live
alone
CH kind of a kid creates an invisible
[Music]
if don't uh don't don't look him in the
eye
which one you know damn well which
one thanks for doing this it really
means a whole
lot it is time to take the next step on
your journey I'm not going to be the
Dragon Warrior anymore you will advance
the spiritual leader of The Valley Of
Peace inner
peace inner peace keep your surup off my
turf dinner please
dinner with peas in a sesame so glaze
this is not working at
[Music]
all taang big
fan once I possess the Kung Fu of every
Master villain no one will dare question
my power not even the Great Dragon
Warrior who's that the most powerful
shape-shifting sorceress the chameleon
how do I find this the chameleon I'm
going to lead you right to her front
door it was against an
army then we'll just have to get an army
of our own what is this place the best
Crooks and criminals live here you're a
wanted criminal you sound surprised is
it
surprising now you kids be careful with
those
fireworks vience makes our tummies
tingle why should we help you we can
take down the chameleon together being
the Dragon Warrior it's who I am SC what
do I know about being a spiritual leader
what is it you're holding a cookie you
were chosen to become something more
than you already
[Music]
are how should we do this quick and
painless or slow and painful slow and
painful
you finally met your match
chameleon We're Not So Different you and
I stand back I'm going to kick my
butt
what don't touch it I saw this movie
Once where they come across this
box and they open the box the
case and it was like really really
bad I just want to know what's going on
I bet it's
locked
you just want to locate your friends who
are you jackass that's when do women
curse like
that those girls just drove off with
something we
need we got to call the cops cool your
JS here's what we do sell it back shake
them down that is about the dumbest
thing I've ever heard and I'm a cop yeah
[Music]
baby who are you save the sanctimony and
hand over to the million smackers where
you we should see what's in
here ralway dolls
wear what the hell yeah we forgot to
tell you about the swab guys head in the
Hat Box only theaters February
23rd I've been waiting 40 years for this
they called themselves Ghostbusters
according to these hacks they saved the
world no
eyewitnesses
and who is found to carry the torch
descendants of Egon Spangler you have a
minor hanging out the side of a moving
vehicle firing a laser gun
indiscriminately has a proton back it's
completely safe I wouldn't say
completely safe the Ghostbusters are
finished right well overruled
sustained thank
you you the weird guy who byy strange
old things correct on both counts buddy
you just hit the jackpot
what is it better question is what's
inside of
it The Parables tell of an unimaginable
evil commanding an Army of
Ghosts with the power to kill by fear
itself like literally scared to
[Music]
death we might be looking at our second
Ice
Age we're going to need all the help we
can get let's get to
work can I be of any help melet in
uniform
yes is there something
strange if there's something weird what
are people going to call Ghostbusters
what do you
[Music]
want we the Ghostbusters can I tell you
something else what Buster makes me feel
good makes me feel
good heads up it's all dark and horny at
[Music]
12:00
yeah oh hell
no [__] move hey PG-13
please what was that Lord is the queen
be Regina George don't look her in the
eye you could be really hot if you
change like
everything welcome to Health and Human
Sexuality we will be getting into
abstinence of course Then followed by in
the spring condoms and choking you're
learning things now that I don't know
how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet Baby
E we as women have to be able to support
each other get in loser welcome Katie
you're never going to believe what I
found this morning yourth burn book mom
go make snacks for sure for sure Regina
yeah do you like gum sure oh no I don't
have any I was just you're a mess we
will help you
caddy why are you dressed so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
[__] that is [__] shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay what all we've done is to make
Regina hotter and revive the wet look
dance
break who wrote all this
[Music]
junk Katie pushed her Regina really
should be lifting through her
[Music]
glutes look at this thing I can't see it
like a face
breath my p k inor you have to pick a
French name Chanel
no no
[Music]
beon
oh
oh hi there little
[Music]
buddy you hungry little
guy you want a little
[Music]
more and that's how I adopted
John okay now have youever with
a please no it's so hot it's really
hurting ow ow ow you deserve to be seen
with somebody is black
say when never John bury me in cheese oh
I apologize in advance the eating you're
about to see will not be pretty and if
you have young children this would be a
good time for them to leave the
room hey Junior this is fck my father
you ever jumped a train I've never
jumped here's I stop really
where
[Applause]
oh OD you think he'd see that coming
let's get it I deserve to
be the mystery of the obscene little
Hampton Letts is causing widespread
distress Across the
Nation AIS Swan takes it up the and she
loves it more than Christmas day only
words mother she sucks 10 a week minimum
holy Heavens in the end I think it's
just
jealousy Rose goody you are writing
these Wicked little letters to Edith's
want why would I send a letter when I
can just say it I'll get you in the ball
sir she's
heinous you want in the nose you old
beetle beetle
right you're charging her what's the
evidence let me on you w time
similarities in the language I've got a
daughter at home why would I risk it all
in prison Rose my find some Kindred
Spirits in prison no no not the murders
or the rapists I'm thinking more the
drunks and the queers maybe just trying
to find a bright
side I believe we may be charging an
innocent if you meddle in my case these
will be on your wrists makes me wonder I
think you've been set up Rose is there
anyone who want to do such a
thing we got a pen and
paper I like you Rose I ha
her you don't like the idea of me living
this house
dear you are a Serial liar we'll find
who wrote these
letters oh god oh
Jesus I noticed they say foxy out a lot
nobody swears out that what would you
say you look like Queen Victoria
sh you
[Music]
D this is a story about me Leah and T
how is the shop doing well it is
it seems like you are making something
of
yourself it's a Chinese tradition to
have your fortune T before
[Music]
begin we can celebrate Le success well
in
control five days Jesus has answered my
[Music]
prayer we each pick one date and I have
the perfect man in mind I have a $50 bet
on my date Dad I'm not some slot machine
Leah don't say
[__] come you will be my public facing
wife wait
what what she needs is someone who is
loyal yeah you have to try it what did
you say this again oh my
[Applause]
God oh my
gosh my God something Di oh and they
were buried in your
mouth Richard it's good to see you mhm
oh this is a nightmare not meeting
anyone
you Grandma I know what you're going to
say suck it up and get back out
there dating is just a numbers game and
your number happens to be
five in 6 months we'll begin trying for
children Three Sons
minimum my grandma told me to follow my
dreams
it's you feeling I'm the
failure even though I'm still prettier
it's all I
[Music]
have why is this the best date so far if
you want to do some over the pants stuff
we oh good I was dreading it
to hello loyal viewer
for those who are just joining us that's
me mega mine master of all villain until
I realized my destiny was to be a
superhero Megamind is back I'm kind of a
big deal and you're welcome you're all
so lucky to have me as your hero wow you
were threatening the city a few days ago
now you're defending it I want to be a
crime fighter just like you you're
adorable in a pushy sort of way here's a
souvenir it's either a paper weight or a
flash grenade so careful with that from
Dreamworks Animation the Doom Syndicate
I despise them more than button-down
callers okay Mega mine is that any way
to welcome your old crew you still think
I'm a villain let's have a b
oldfashioned crime spree or let's have
some fun before jumping into evil
business shrads anyone no act like a
villain until I can stop them we must
keep up evil appearances sounds pretty
deep
think like a hero those bystanders are
about to get squished it does not look
good for them oh right I'm a hero now
time to kick some Doom Syndicate
booty oh guess it was a flash grenade
mega mind versus the Doom Syndicate the
new film and if you love mega mind as
much as he does me is one of my favorite
things in the whole wide world keep the
fun going with mega mind rules the new
series
[Music]
I know you can feel their discomfort
Aaron watching you walk through a room
full of white people was the most
painful thing I've ever seen excuse me
sorry I want to take you to a job
interview there's a recruiting class
starting right now and we got to get you
in
it welcome to the American
society of magical
Negroes I don't really understand it's
easier to
sh what's the most dangerous animal on
the planet sharks white people when they
feel uncomfortable white people feeling
uncomfortable precedes a lot of bad
stuff for us that's why we fight white
discomfort every day because the happier
they are the safer we are the name is
little updating maybe like
magical black people or I guess that
doesn't have the same ring
you ready oh wow your first client is a
Jason M his morale is far too low hey
hey darn it I was hoping there was a
station right next to him oh is this one
spoken for no yeah it's actually fun and
weirdly relaxing it's like being a
secret agent with none of the danger hey
I'm Lizzy nice to meet you nice to meet
you she's great yeah she's cool you
kidding come on man she's smart and
funny I know what you were doing going
on about her you're trying to set us up
no no no that's not what I was doing you
cannot have a relationship with Lizzy
now because if you don't put Jason first
everyone's magic will
fail I've always felt like it's my job
to make white people feel comfortable
and here it literally
is but maybe it shouldn't be I got a
great plan to ask her out but I'm going
to need your help do you think you can
like work your magic hey is you talking
about me hey oh my wait are you but I've
Tred a long
way someone defied the society who was
you didn't let her go like I told you if
you interfere with her or your client
you could have your memory erased you
won't even remember she
existed even though we might never see
each other again I need you to know that
what we had was
real I'm curious to see how you going to
make it out of all
[Music]
this you want to be a normal teenager I
got news for you you're not normal Doris
who's
Doris uh I
am do you think this is the right place
for him you could say that about any
place my brother's dying he hasn't
talked in years I'm so sorry my wife
passed away my dad died when I was three
Christ it ain't a
competition I think I should start
sleeping at Sunco so your brother
doesn't get too lonely he's my child
when he's in pain I'm in pain I'm your
child too what about God's sake give me
a break you can come to my house if you
need to place a party my mom mom won't
be there and you can do whatever you
want oh God I I have to tell everybody
um but who who are
you everyone says this neighborhood is
scary but like when you're in it it's
like not that
scary thank
you it's really hard taking care of sick
people sometimes you need a
break I dare need to kiss
D he could have died and you weren't
here
once your brother's gone he's
gone and you will miss taking care of
him you'll miss everything all the good
all the
bad we're going to have fun again you
and
me I'll learn how to be fun
again Doris old lady's name it was my
grandma's name oh she died the day I was
born my God is there any conversation
with you that is not like thoroughly
depressing to
[Music]
me America loves a
superstar Jason 2 J's Jennings I was
like football leure but once you reach
the Mountaintop of greatness everybody
wants to see you
fall two days this guy smoked damn you
play guilty to charges of speeding and
damage to city property I'm recommending
community service with the Long Beach
Recreations department I thought I was
getting like some Martha Stewart kind of
treatment you too good for the community
that raised you the of the
[Music]
sea I am football legend Jason 2 J's
Jennings your new head coach Legend let
me get a picture with y'all will put for
20 some of y'all going to get some
girlfriends with this right
here key Karine Jason I've been trying
to get back in touch with you for years
I know you've been thinking about me and
I know you've been trying to get in
touch with me CU that pretty much right
you just put a gun in my head relax Jay
the safety was on oh no it wasn't on
what imagine
that before we can be the best we got to
master the
fundamentals pretty boy you missing pass
after pass you got on all that sweet ass
swag the next time you come out here
acting like a fake ass rapper we going
to kick your ass out the field stop
acting like you got an album coming
out JJ how you liking this game coach
this is a mess I don't know what I'm
doing do you remember what you were like
when you showed up freshman year you
were pain in the ass I want nobody
nothing sound just like me if you really
want to win a game stop pushing away
your
team let's
go look like a black princess layer
underdogs on three underdogs on me one 2
3 what my
[Music]
name I got your mascots right here beat
Killer and squiller two dos for two G's
I found them chained up in the back of
the winner
[Music]
snitch hi are you the actor Andy Samberg
I am I'm a big fan man oh thank you very
much hey I got a question for
you you want to get
in Thomas Walcott single no children no
dependence job is Network management
physically
fit guess they're not too strict about
that one I'm joking it's kind of serious
though you have been selected to partake
in the biggest reality show in the dark
web there will be people trying to kill
you the hunters what are you talking
about there people trying to murder
me oh [__] very much so you will have 30
days to survive you will only be killed
when you are alone so let me get this
straight you cannot touch me if I'm with
someone and then I get a million
dollars what are you doing what are you
doing man why' you leave my side I
didn't take a [__] why didn't you wake
me up and bring me with you because I'm
taking a [__]
let's
play what the [__] is this this is James
my new friend he pay me to Shadow him
you cannot have this person sleeping in
Mom's house are you going to Shadow me
no are you going to Shadow me no sh are
you going to Shadow me I don't want to
take away James's
job this is going to end badly aren't
there other people playing the game who
could hang out with you just say it
you're not going to no I'm not going to
murder you are you going to murder me no
I want to be on the same team as you you
want to spend all our time together
after knowing me for 5 minutes let's
[__] win
[Music]
together they can't kill us if we're
together right okay good night I hope no
one murders either of
you wake up you are not as safe as you
think you
are hi
guys
will where are you playing the game I
guess I did it cuz I want to be around
people more I think we did it for the
same reason I don't want to burst your
bubble but the game is a comedy how is
it a comedy they're trying to [__]
kill
[Music]
us get in the
car you been having fun did you just ask
about was having fun um yes
no I was fully dreading coming to this
wedding until you showed
up could I get a cranberry juice with
ice and vodka when I first saw you I
thought that we should have sex in the
Cod
closet yeah
yeah wait hold on I am kind of in a
weird place yeah you're in a beach club
coat closet do you think that we could
just talk for a
minute romantic humiliations it's my
specialty I don't care the first person
to ever go down on me we just going to
steamroll right on through I came in my
own
eye okay go
on I've had too many girlfriends over
the past couple years I can't figure it
out out yeah we've all been there tell
me what I'll give you some of this pie
if you tell me more about your
[Music]
past it's not like I don't come with my
own complications we're engaged
oh wait you were
engaged lasted 13 days impressive that
is incredibly insulting but I see what
you mean will you walking into the train
station I actually have class no you
don't I like this Chi she's really hot I
know just wish I would have ended things
more
gracefully you ever see her
again this would never work you are
someone who cannot be counted on you've
run out on every guy you've ever been
with I'm a mess and I don't have any
answers but maybe you and I could figure
it out
together
usually I feel so alone in my memories
but it's different with
you I'm happy to tell you a few more
embarrassing stories about my love life
well I promise not to laugh [__] I
promise not to laugh
[Music]
much my bridesmaid entrances are the
stuff of Legends ever the bridesmaid
that is my badge of honor you feel me I
feel you
I go to weddings and baby showers every
damn weekend when are you going to give
me grandkids talk to your firstborn
about grandchildren I don't want him
procreating no that's terrifying thought
nobody wants that nobody wants that I
don't have a man or any legit prospects
what have I ever done am I not suitable
for life you are very suitable for Life
feel like I'm running out of time are
you seeing anyone now I'm seeing
everyone now it's sort of an all you can
eat buffet how old are you please say 32
or 33 Nelly
I'm
stupid I want you to remember they can
be a never Neverland Never Growing Up
never aging but those eggs they
are if I don't spend 13k to freeze my
eggs I might never be able to have kids
meanwhile you're going to wait till
you're 70 to have a baby with an
influencer that is accurate and I'm not
embarrassed about it what's new with you
Nelly I'm thinking about getting my egg
Frozen that's amazing maybe I should
have a baby shower but you're not having
a
baby what if I screw this up I don't
even know if I want kid I've seen
Euphoria you're not going to screw this
[Music]
upo you're buying time someone who's
good enough for you is hard to come
by I'm either going to a Renaissance or
amidst the worst crisis of my
lifetime
here we go down here you look like I'd
say fortun definitely not
[Applause]
okay everyone ready okay here we go that
is Maurice the Great Tiger Warrior and
that is Junior his son the little tiger
Warrior over there is Patricia and that
is Miguel and there is the brains of the
bunch it's me Gilbert our mission if we
choose to accept it is to come to the
help of any animal who needs it all
right Betty by great tiger Warriors need
their sleep too and it's not as if bad
guys are going to come and attack Us in
the
night tonight begins a brand new era for
the jungle tonight history will be
Rewritten the jungle is covered with a
dangerous substance that if it comes
into contact with water will destroy all
vegetation I got to have a pee
pee what can we do about it well uh we
need an antidote that will will save the
jungle it can only be found in one place
and it's far far away it's one of the
most dangerous places on Earth angelous
come on how bad can it
[Music]
be hi there friend can you help
us oh boy Migel nasty
Panda you have to stop them understood
yes
Bo yes we did it
yorri wow this is a perfect little boat
come on we've got a jungle to save here
we
go when the storms come the jungle will
be transformed into a desert oh no no
don't worry Gilbert we'll help you yep
and we'll do do it inide someone stop
that
table you're forcing me to pull out all
the stops ah
[Music]
Arnold yep I knew it we're going to
fight